okay we got to revisit for just a second
a couple of points there's a rule in
economics if you in capitalism which is
what we operate under even though some
of you don't like that and you're
communists but in capitalism which is
actually what we operate under if you
leave people alone you do not interfere
in the market you don't artificially
stimulate the market the correct amount
of buyers will go to the correct amount
of goods at the correct price by correct
I mean if you're running a restaurant
and you suck at cooking the correct
amount of people you have eating at your
restaurant will be zero at any price if
you're great at cooking and you cook
hamburgers you're going to get one price
if you're great at cooking filet mignon
you're going to get another price if
your wine list is in a box you're going
to get one price if your wine list is
fine French or the best of Napa you're
gonna get another price if however the
government decides they want to fool
with that and they want to get people
into the hamburger business and so they
give people in the hamburger business
free money or cheap money because they
insure it then that interferes in that
equation the same is true with the
purchase of this thing called education
you pay for education without
interference in the economics with the
cost of student loans if student loans
are out of the equation suddenly people
have to pay for their education now will
fewer people be able to afford it at the
current rate yes with the current rate
go down yes the reason college tuition
is driven up is not because college
operators are all greedy because almost
none of them are they don't make that
much money it's because they have no
limit on the amount of money they have
to spend because people will borrow out
the wazoo to go to their college because
18 year-olds don't do well adding
apparently my
and large thus we have a 1.3 trillion
dollar student loan crisis because the
government has interfered in the
economics of the cost of an education
I'm all about education I'm not anti
education but I'm all about capitalism
controlling the cost and the supply and
the demand of and the price of a good or
service it's that simple why do you
think the cost of music has gone down
the supply and demand you can buy and
you can buy you know we used to buy a
record for $27 now you buy a song for a
buck 29 it's a different world harder to
make money in the music business now but
the ease of distribution all of these
things affect economics basic economics
and we've destroyed the economics of
higher education with the student loan
program it's time for it to go away
now second piece Mike Marui this article
how many people have been exploding on
social media everywhere this guy has
been destroyed he really has become a
laughingstock and he's become a you know
a symbol of what's wrong with this thing
but the port guy is just a guy he's just
a guy being a dentist he's trying to
have a life with a couple kids he's
trying to figure his way through this
and truthfully people in the medical
profession of the world's worst and
handling money and he's just proof of
that - so Mike really I'm not mad at you
and I know half the world's mad at you
or whatever it feels like you've been
beat up this week because you probably
had the crap beat out of you I don't
know why you gave them all your numbers
and thought this was going to turn out
well but it didn't so here's the deal I
mean we're we've got a huge brand in
Salt Lake City one of you guys that know
Mike get in touch with him I really will
help him but he's going to do what I
tell him to do and he may not want to do
what I tell him to do because I'm
getting ready to destroy his life but he
know how even have a life right now his
life sucks yeah I mean it sounds like
he's got it made he's got to use Tesla
what is that a 30 what is it Alan
Mulally said the other day it's a seven
it's a thirty thousand dollar car with a
$70,000 battery yeah
pretty funny line but anyway the this is
a used one
that's the guy that used to be president
of Ford I'm quoting there by the way but
anyway the yeah get in touch with us
just email one of y'all email Kelly at
Dave on-air at Dave Ramsey's comment
sincere offer we'll fly you and your
wife over to Nashville at our expense
and we'll sit you down with our coaches
and you're going to do exactly what we
tell you to do or we're going to drop
you like a hot potato back into your
mess but if you will submit yourself to
this I can get you out of this you're
going to work all the time you're going
to have no life and make no money for a
while but you're not gonna have 25 years
of hell either you got 25 years of hell
is your prescription right now and it's
no life you're just trapped and I can
show you how to pay this off you have
the earning ability to do this and
you're just going to cut your lifestyle
and I can do I can fix this for you do
these numbers are doable they're not as
you're not as trapped as it sounds like
you are it's not gonna be easy but it's
doable and we will help you and we won't
charge you a thing and you and your wife
will fly here on I add our expense just
because I hate forgot to get piled on
like this this is all I mean can you
imagine being this guy right now the
hate he's getting I mean goodness
because people are merciless we live in
a society of trolls now and when they
get mad about an idea they attack people
and it's crazy y'all are violent it's
ridiculous so anyway I'm violently angry
about the situation he's in I'm not mad
at him I've been stupid too and you and
our stupid because we set it up where he
could do that we're the taxpayers it's
our fault too so it's got to stop y'all
it's got to stop and it's time for it to
stop